- I'm Brian Hill.
And we're playing Start Bench Cut.
I'm gonna be given a category
and I gotta pick one start, one to bench, and one to cut.
I'll bench Friday Night Lights.
'Cause I like the show better than a movie.
Cut Rudy.
And, you know I gotta start Remember The Titans.
Denzel, easy come on.
I want my ring.
I'll start telepathy.
It'd be pretty cool to know what people thinking.
You know, especially in a quiet room.
Super strength's overrated,
I'll go, cut super strength.
Bench super speed.
Dang.
Aight, I'mma starting Rick and Morty.
I been on Rick and Morty,
I can't wait to finish season four.
I'm gonna cut South Park.
And I'm gonna bench Spongebob.
I can't just let go of Spongebob like that.
Favorite Spongebob episode,
when Squidward finally ate a krabby patty.
Yeah then he got fat man.
Spongebob's face when he finally caught him.
Funniest thing ever.
Dang, that ain't easy.
But I'm gonna start pizza.
Pizza my favorite food of course.
That dip and them wings though.
That's hard.
I'm gonna cut the dip,
bench the wings.
I can't get rid of the wings,
you need the wings at a party man.
We cuttin' Madden,
until they put my speed up from 88,
I'm faster than Free.
We gonna bench Call of Duty, I barely play that.
Grand Theft Auto you can do anything.
So we startin' that.
That's hard.
But I'll probably start Serena.
Just because what she's doing is crazy,
nobody ever done that.
I will bench Tiger 'cause like I said with Serena,
you know they undisputed number one.
Tom Brady, I feel like he the number one quarter back
of all time but you can still argue that
so I'm gonna cut him.
I mean there's a lot of great quarterbacks who play
this game so it's a good argument.
But the other two, you know they undisputed.
I barely listen to Jay-Z, so I'm gonna cut The Blueprint.
Bench Get Rich or Die Tryin'.
You know we starting Tha Carter three baby, Wheezy.
I'm Brian Hill and this is Start Bench Cut.